sosont à l'intérieur, c'est des
prproduits qui nous ont demandé
auau niveau de l'école.
- - Ce père vient de compléter
seses achats pour la rentrée
scscolaire de son fils.
- - D'habitude, on paie maximum
16160 pièces pour l'année,
mamais comme aujourd'hui, j'étas
ététonné, on m'a fait une factue
àà 341 dollars pour un élève
dede primaire de 4e année.
- - Il nous a spontanément fait
papart de ses impressions
susur sa facture.
- - C'est vraiment une catastroe
popour les classes pauvres.
- - Je ne vous ai même pas posé
dede question.
- - Oh! Moi, j'ai repondu à tous
leles questions!
(r(rires)
- - Il a fait ses emplettes dans
cecette papeterie de Montréal
tetenue par une ancienne
iningénieure qui a changé
dede vocation par passion.
ElElle constate que le coût
dede certains produits a bondi
cocomparativement à l'an dernie.
SiSi on regarde un sac-à-dos
papar exemple...
MOMONICA POPA
prpropriétaire, Papeterie Léo
- - Mais, juste pour un exemple,
reregardez, l'année passée, je s
vevendais comme à 39,41 $
plplus taxes, cette année,
ilils sont rendus à 49 $.
- - Monica Popa estime qu'en
momoyenne l'augmentation des prx
dedes effets scolaires est
d'd'environ 15 % cette année
mamais...
- - Il y en a des items qui sont
mmême à 30 %. Oui, je sais,
nonous aussi on a fait le saut.
- PoPour faire face à la hausse,
OpOption consommateur suggère
lala préparation du fameux budgt
etet aussi de récupérer
cece qui peut l'être.
JOJOHANNE LE BLANC, conseillère,
OpOption consommateurs
- - Évidemment, on commence par
fafaire l'inventaire des matérix
ququ'on a déjà et qui sont
rérécupérables de l'année
prprécédente. Il ne faut pas
héhésiter aussi à faire des
écéchanges peut-être avec des
fafamilles, amis, qui ont certas
efeffets dont ils n'ont plus
bebesoin.
- - En fait, ce que j'ai fait,
c'c'est que je suis allée voir
dadans ce que les enfants avaiet
dédéjà. Donc on le fait encore
plplus cette année.
- - On a pas le choix, c'est une
dédépense qui est nécessaire als
onon fait avec.
- - Ceux qui écoppent, ce sont
susurtout les familles à faibles
rerevenus.
- - Il y a le 2-1-1 qui est une
reressource pour vous aider
àà trouver des ressources selon
lele quartier ou la ville
ouoù vous habitez.
- - Parfait, merci.
- - ICI Mélissa François,
R Radio-Canada, Montréa